.
>> Sean: THANKS FOR THAT REPORT
FROM MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
TONIGHT ONE LIBERAL COUNTY IN
TEXAS IS INVESTIGATING RON
DESANTIS.
THEY ARE ACCUSING HIM OF LEAVING
MIGRANTS TO FEND FOR THEMSELVES
IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
HERE TO RESPOND IS FLORIDA
GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS.
THE IRONY IS IF WE USE THE
LEFT'S DEFINITION OF RACISM AND
XENOPHOBIA, THEY DEFINE IT.
WHAT THEY'RE MISSING IS JOE
BIDEN HAS BEEN FLYING AND
BUSSING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS EVERY
DAY ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN THE
DARK OF NIGHT JUST LEAVING THEM
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE STREET.
WHY ARE THEY ONLY NOW PAYING
ATTENTION TO 50 PEOPLE YOU SENT?
>> WELL, SEAN, IT'S FRUSTRATING.
YOU HAVE BEEN COVERING THIS.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE SINCE BIDEN
HAS BEEN PRESIDENT ILLEGALLY
COMING ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
DID THEY FREAK OUT?
NO.
YOU HAD MIGRANTS DIE IN THE RIO
GRANDE AND 50 DIE IN A TRAILER?
THEY HAVE VICTIMIZED AMERICANS,
KILLING SOME AND RAPING SOME.
ANY OUTRAGE?
NO.
AND FENTANYL IS COMING OVER THE
OPEN SOUTHERN BORDER.
IT'S ONLY WHEN 50 ARE PUT IN
MARTHA'S VINEYARD -- THEY SAID
THEY WANTED THIS THIS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO WERE
DESTITUTE AND PUT IN A SITUATION
WHERE THEY COULD HAVE SUCCEEDS,
NOT ONLY DID THEY NOT WELCOME
THEM.
THEY DEPARTED THEM THE NEXT DAY
WITH THE NATIONAL GUARD -- GIVE
ME A BREAK!
>> Sean: THIS WAS VOLUNTARY.
ALL MIGRANTS WERE PUT UP IN
HOTELS AND FED AND SHOWERED AND
OFFERED HAIRCUTS, CORRECT?
>> YES.
NOT ONLY THAT, THEY ALL SIGNED
CONSENT FORMS TO GO.
THE VENDOR DOING THIS FOR
FLORIDA PROVIDED THEM WITH
A PACKET WITH A MAP OF MARTHA'S
VINEYARD AND THE NUMBERS FOR
DIFFERENT SERVICES ON MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
IT HAD NUMBERS FOR THE OVERALL
AGENCIES IN MASSACHUSETTS THAT
HANDLE THINGS INVOLVING
IMMIGRATION AND REFUGEES.
IT WAS VOLUNTARY.
ALL OF THE OTHER NONSENSE IS NOT
TRUE.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY WANT TO GO
GIVEN WHERE THEY WERE?
THEY WERE IN REALLY, REALLY BAD
SHAPE.
THEY GOT TO BE CLEANED UP AND
TREATED WELL AND PUT IN
A SITUATION -- THERE ARE JOBS
AVAILABLE IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
THERE IS LODGING AVAILABLE IN
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
THEY LIVED UP TO WHAT THEY BILL
THEMSELVES AS THEY COULD HAVE
ABSORBED THOSE PEOPLE WITHOUT
A PROBLEM.
THEY SAID THEY DIDN'T HAVE
HOUSING.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR THE POOR
TOWNS IN TEXAS AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THAT SEE AN INFLUX AND
THE SMALL TOWNS THAT BIDEN
DUMPED SO MANY PEOPLE IN?
WE HAVE SHOWN THAT THIS BORDER
IS A DISASTER.
BIDEN FAILED ON THIS AS MUCH OR
MORE THAN ANY OTHER POLICY.
PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT T. WE
WANT SOLUTIONS AS AMERICANS.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
TRUMP'S POLICIES OVER REMAIN IN
MEXICO CAN BE REINSTITUTEED TO
GET CONTROL OVER WHAT IS GOING
ON DOWN THERE.
>> Sean: IT'S HARD TO FATHOM.
19 MONTHS AGO OUR BORDERS WERE
SECURED.
WE HAD STAY IN MEXICO.
ELIMINATED CATCH AND RELEASE.
NOW WE GIVE THEM A FREE PHONE.
YOU DON'T GET A COVID VACCINE
MANDATE.
THIS IS MADNESS.
WE HAD OUR BORDERS CONTROLLED
AND 1.4% INFLATION AND NOT 8.5%.
WE ARE PLAYING DOUBLE THE AMOUNT
FOR GASOLINE.
WE WOULD HAVEN'T HAD A DISASTER
IN AFGHANISTAN.
ALL OF THIS HAPPENED IN 19
MONTHS.
WHO DO YOU SEE AS THE ANSWER 50
DAYS FROM NOW WHEN AMERICANS GO
THE VOTING BOOTH AND YOU ARE UP
FOR REELECTION?
>> THEY ACCUSED OF GOVERNORS OF
ARIZONA, TEXAS AND ME OF
POLITICAL STUNTS DEALING WITH
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THE BIGGEST STUNT WAS BIDEN
COMING IN TO OFFICE AND
REVERSING TRUMP'S POLICIES.
NOT BECAUSE TRUMP'S POLICIES
WERE NOT WORKING.
HE REVERSED THEM BECAUSE HE
WANTED TO VIRTUE SIGNAL TO HIS
BASE AND SHOW THAT DONALD TRUMP
WAS BAD.
HE REVERSED IT KNOWING WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN.
HE HAS PULLED THE BIGGEST
POLITICAL STUNT.
PEOPLE NEED TO PRESS THE CASE IN
THE MID-TERMS.
THE ECONOMY WILL BE A BIG ISSUE.
CRIME WILL BE A HUGE ISSUE.
THIS IMMIGRATION AND BORDER IS
NOW A FRONT BURNER ISSUE.
THIS IS ONE WHERE REPUBLICANS
HAVE THE ADVANTAGE WITHOUT
QUESTION.
RUN ON IT AND IF WE GET
MAJORITIES IN THE CONGRESS, DO
SOMETHING WITH THAT POWER.
>> Sean: I THINK BORDER, ENERGY,
LAW AND TAXES AND LAW AND ORDER
AND PARENTAL RIGHTS AND
EDUCATION.
I HOPE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE
WHAT FOR WHAT IT IS.
I DON'T WANT TO ASK THIS YES
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK GAVIN
NEWSOM IS BRIGHT.
I WILL ASK ANYWAY.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE HIM EXPLAIN
WHY HE SHUT DOWN CALIFORNIA.
THEY COULD NOT GO OUT TO EAT.
HE WENT OUT TO EAT.
LET HIS KIDS HAVE IN SCHOOL
EDUCATION.
EVERY OTHER KID WERE FORCED TO
STUDY REMOTE.
I WOULD LIKE HIM TO EXPLAIN
13.5% STATE INCOME TAX TO YOUR
ZERO PERCENT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE MEANT BY
THE KIDNAPPING COMMENT.
I HAVE NO CLUE.
>> ARE,
-- WELL, WEX
OF PEOPLE FROM CALIFORNIA.
THEY ARE MOVING BECAUSE THEY ARE
DISSATISFIED THERE.
ANY TIME YOU ARE THERE YOU HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT THE DIFFERENT
THINGS WITH CRIME AND
HOMELESSNESS.
COULD THEY EVEN KEEP THE LIGHTS
ON?
THEY HAVE PROBLEMS WITH THAT AS
WELL.
WE ARE HAPPY WITH WHAT WE ARE
DOING IN FLORIDA.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, PEOPLE
CAN POLITICALLY CAN SAY ALL OF
THIS STUFF.
LOOK AT PEOPLE BEHAVE.
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING FOR FREEDOM.
WE ARE THE FIRST PLACE THEY
LOOK.
NOT JUST FROM NEW YORK AND NEW
JERSEY AND NOT JUST FROM THE
MIDWEST.
EVEN FROM THE PACIFIC COAST OF
THIS IT COUNTRY GOING ACROSS
NORTH AMERICA TO LIVE IN THE
STATE OF FLORIDA.
WE ARE PROUD WE HAVE BEEN THAT
SYMBOL FOR MANY PEOPLE.
>> Sean: GOVERNOR, FOR THE
FIREFIGHT  -- FIRST TIME IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY THEY HAD
A DECREASE IN POPULATION.
HOW MANY NEW PEOPLE MOVE TO
FLORIDA ON A DAILY BASIS?
DO YOU HAVE AN EXACT NUMBER?
I DON'T HAVE AN IMPACT NUMBER.
WE HAD OVER 222,000 THE LAST 2
YEARS -- AND MORE WEALTH MOVE
INTO FLORIDA THAN ANY OTHER
STATE IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
WHO IS LOSING THE MOST
POPULATION AND THE MOST WEALTH?
CALIFORNIA, NEW YORK, AND
ILLINOIS.
>> Sean: VERY WELL SAID.
YOU ARE OUT ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL.
YOUR RACE IS PIVOTAL FOR
REPUBLICANS AND SO IS MARCO
RUBIO'S.
YOU HAVE BEEN DOING CAMPAIGNING
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WHAT ARE THE ARGUMENTS YOU WOULD
MAKE?
TO ME IT'S SIMPLE.
THE LIST WE WENT OVER.
ARE YOU BETTER OFF THAN YOU WERE
19 MONTHS AGO IN TERMS OF YOUR
ENERGY PRICES AND BORDER
SECURITY?
ARE YOU BETTER OFF WITH A STATE
THAT CLOSED DOWN WITH COVID.
YOU HAD KIDS IN SCHOOL IN AUGUST
OF 2020.
WHAT ARGUMENTS SHOULD
REPUBLICANS BE MAKING?
>> WELL, FIRST HERE IN FLORIDA,
PEOPLE ARE FIRED UP.
OUR VOTERS WANT TO COME OUT.
I THINK WE VAIL RECORD SETTING
TURNOUT AMONG REPUBLICANS.
I AM RUNNING.
SENATE RUBIO AND CONGRESSIONAL
RACES AND SCHOOL BOARDS.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
I THINK WE WILL DO REALLY WELL.
YOU NAILED IT IT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, PROSECUTE THE CASE
AGAINST WHAT BIDEN HAS DONE.
THINGS WERE CHEAPER BEFORE HE
WAS PRESIDENT.
GAS WAS SHARP.
OUR -- CHEAPER.
OUR COUNTRY WAS SAFER.
HIT HIM ON CRIME AND OUR BORDER
WAS MORE SECURE AND PARENTS
RIGHTS IN EDUCATION.
THE LEFT HAS GONE SO RADICAL.
AMERICAN PEOPLE THINK SCHOOL
SHOULD BE TO EDUCATE KIDS.
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE ON
CRITICAL RACE THEORY AND GENDER
IDENTITY.
EVERY SINGLE DEMOCRAT WILL HAVE
TO SUPPORT THAT BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT THE FAR LEFT OF THEIR BASE
WANTS TO SEE.
>> Sean: DO YOU HAVE ANY
INTEREST IN DEBATING GAVIN
NEWSOM ON HIS RECORD STATE
INCOME TAXES?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THEY CAN KEEP
THE POWER ON.
YOU GO UP TO HAVE A DEBATE.
WE ARE HAPPY WITH WHAT WE ARE
DOING.
MY ACTIONS SPEAK LOUDER THAN MY
WORDS.
CERTAIN PEOPLE WILL PREEN.
WE GET THINGS DONE IN FLORIDA.
>> Sean: WHATEVER YOU DO, DON'T
CHARGE YOUR ELECTR